the Joe Rogan experience you know did
you see that New York Times review they
gave the [ __ ] Brooklyn Steakhouse
that we love what the hell's it called
Peter Lugar's the gate Peter Lugar's one
star one star that member we just went
there yeah it was [ __ ] amazing
my god it's dude those potatoes they
gave it one star alright three stars
that you're like well maybe something
happened I don't know it's smart because
look if you're a provocateur /
journalists and I know how much you love
trolls yeah that's really one of the
most delicious restaurants of all time
and he made a one star rating it's
either that or he's a [ __ ]
so either he's really clever kind of or
easy he's got to be a [ __ ] up on top of
Google when you search Peter Luger
review so now it sputters I can't why
star I can't count on Peter Luger state
guys are booking to produce certain
sensations and then I don't know well
it's a very very popular restaurant
right there's a giant waiting list last
time we were there and we luckily
weaseled in and had to grease some palms
but it's a [ __ ] sweet spot India's
went when Diaz is in town he was like
get a reservation like getting look
you're right here man you can't get one
so we had my manager assistant call and
say were part of Obama's staff they said
we could do 3:15 and that's it oh my god
yeah yeah the food's there is [ __ ]
amazing
once our restaurant you've come not one
star at the troll you're absolutely
right that's that's more than he's not
just he's just he's one of those writers
there's certain writers that are just
trying to be [ __ ] with everything
they do they love being [ __ ] they
love accentuating you live the art form
of being an [ __ ] an art form of being
an articulate [ __ ] you're an [ __ ]
with good food you know how to say that
you know put the right words in the
right order which just sounds juicy and
pops and makes you seem terrible but we
don't know or something like Peter
Lugar's like you lose that all that one
star means that's not what one star
means know what one star means your face
you go to the Olive Garden and the
[ __ ] guy works behind the counter his
heroin problem zero stars
zero they didn't give it a one as the
zero star that so like I haven't even
there's no zero star one is the lowest
today come on what that's a Photoshop
that's that really you can't do zero
stars it's a Photoshop see it's more
showing this guy's trolling anyway look
we're talking about it's gray and he's a
smart man son cover him though and we
uncovered him
if you want to make a [ __ ] splash in
the restaurant review business in 2019
that's what you do yeah shitty place
it'll work negative you know you all
love this we're like hey I [ __ ] in your
mouth yeah I mean he was talking about
the the state not being flavorful your
[ __ ] minds
they dropped it on the floor picked it
up on the way it's still a two-star he's
good he's bullshitting and they're all
buying it hook line absolutely got us he
got us hook in the jaw I'm fighting
against the drag uh-huh it's so much
more fun to be angry
[Applause]